tactics to flank / shift a ferocious
analyzer from paralysis to go
meaning what sometimes over things overs
hesitates the landing and planning and
planning and planning well there's a
couple things here if the person is
above you or below you in the chain of
command so if they're below you in the
chain of command you you know you
explain to them you say look we don't
need perfection we're not gonna have
100% solution we don't have 100% of the
information that's a good enough
solution we need to move forward let's
execute and you know what I'll take root
if things go wrong wrong don't worry
about it I'll take responsibility for it
I'm not gonna blame you which is what
you're gonna do anyways as a good leader
so that's what you can do for there
below you in the chain of command if
they're above you in the chain of
command
guess what same thing you gonna tell the
same thing like hey boss we don't need
perfection here look boss we're not
gonna get all the information we need
we're not gonna get a hundred percent
solution we got a 90 percent solution
and let's go for it
and if things do go wrong you can blame
me I don't care so boom the weather that
are above your you know below you the
chain of command you might change your
tact or your verbage a little bit but
it's the same same overall concept
you've got to get them to understand
that we don't need perfection we need to
move forward and the other thing is you
explained the cost of not moving the
cost of staying still the cost of being
reactive instead of proactive in
basically the cost of not being
aggressive because that's what we're
talking about is a lack of aggression
and so what does that look like well you
explain to them that the longer we sit
the better position the enemy gets into
the longer we wait the less we know
about what is actually happening think
about that one the more you sit here and
you're planning the less we know what's
going on out there the things are
happening they're changing they're
evolving the enemy is maneuvering
there's developments on the battlefield
or in the marketplace and you don't even
know because you're sitting in the
planning space hmm the longer we wait
the less time we have to recover if
something does go wrong hmm so if we sit
here and plan for 47 days and on the
40th day we set up out we start to
execute something goes wrong we're not
gonna make the 50 day mark because we
and spent all that time planning so the
longer that you're sitting around the
last time you have to recover and adapt
and adjust and the longer that you wait
while you're doing planning the less
relevant your plan actually becomes so
that's what you need to make people
understand and there's people that are
just habitual and chronic ferocious
analyzers and those are people you gotta
watch but you've got to continually just
get through their head that the more we
sit the more the enemy maneuvers and if
we let them maneuver on us anymore we're
gonna get killed mm-hmm that's it pretty
easy well it's not easy it's a simple
concept it's hard to get people out of
their own heads just like this like
everything else it's hard for the
ferocious analyzer to recognize
themselves as that they think they're
doing a good job they think they're they
think they're actually being thorough
and you're a wild man you're a cowboy
are you crazy yeah no I'm not crazy ever
one time with my first deployment to
Iraq they said hey John this is after
I've been there for a while and they
wanted for some reason they wanted to
know the minimum requirements for us to
go out on an operation and I said I just
need a vicinity of the target and of
radio frequency to talk to the local
conventional units there mmm they were
like well don't you need air support oh
she is like all these other things I was
like no we'll figure it out mmm just
send us yeah we'll go and there was
other things that we would do as we'd
move to our target we aligned things up
and we'd but we we'd be good but
sometimes people wanted to plan out
every last detail well and that doesn't
work the details are not gonna stay the
same the things that you're planning on
are gonna change so don't sit there and
plan every last detail because it's not
gonna help you man that's that's
actually a pretty good point never even
thought about how you say if you spend
too much time planning you know and then
you jump in the game all late it's like
dang you have no time to make any
adjustment it reacts yeah you better go
perfect cuz that's all that's a one shot
you got at it and guess what it's not
gonna go perfect cuz things don't go
perfect yeah things are not gonna go
perfect not gonna happen no such thing
as flawless execution Dave Burke just
wrote an article that was on Business
Insider it's what it was like flawless
execution doesn't happen yeah you know
he was a
gun senior instructor for three years he
knows about flying and he knows how hard
they worked to towards flawless
execution but it didn't exist the false
execution was was analyzing their
mistakes seeing what they can improve
upon that was the father's execution for
them it wasn't the actual act of
flawless execution they you know they
had for all this debriefing flawless
analyzation of what they did wrong yeah
but it wasn't gonna be perfect obstinate
knows no such thing doesn't happen yeah
so if you're sitting and planning that
trying to make that happen it's not
gonna work for you it's don't do it